[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, my name is Reto Meier, and
I'm a tech lead for Google's
Android Developer
Relations team.
One of the most effective ways
you have at your disposal for
optimizing the efficiency of
your data transfers is
eliminating user-driven
updates.
That means doing everything
you can to eliminate the
Refresh button within
your app.
The most common reason people
hit Refresh is because they
don't believe your app is
displaying up-to-date
information.
If you're using some form of
client side polling, they're
probably right.
In fact, every time you create
a repeating alarm to pin your
server to check for updates,
Sundar kills a Bug Droid.
Stop the slaughter and use
Google Cloud Messaging to have
your server notify your app when
there is data ready to be
downloaded, or even include the
new data in the message
payload itself.
If you're using polling, you're
forced to balance data
freshness with the resulting
battery drain.
The more often you poll for
updates, the lower latency
between the data changing on
the server and your app
displaying those updates.
But turning on the radio to
check for those updates, also
drains the battery.
That's the worst of both worlds,
when what you actually
want is no latency
and as little
battery drain as possible.
Google Cloud Messaging helps you
do this by offering a way
to send messages from your
server to any installed
instance of your app.
As a result, you can stop
polling, which will improve
battery life and also improve
the freshness of your app.
Once configured, you can
transmit messages to a
specific app installation or
multicast messages to multiple
recipients.
These messages can be simple
tickles notifying your app
that there's new data ready to
download, or it can include
the new data within the
message payload.
In this Dev.Byte, I focus on
how to use Google Cloud
Messaging to perform more
efficient data transfers.
The details for setting up your
GCM client and server are
detailed comprehensively
in the documentation.
That said, it helps to
understand the GCM data flow.
It starts with your app on each
device registering itself
by sending a registration
message to the GCM
infrastructure.
In return, it will be sent a
registration ID, which will
uniquely identify that instance
of your app running
on that particular device.
You actually send this
identifier to your server,
typically along with a separate
identifier that you
can use to identify a
particular user or
installation.
Your sever now has a way to send
messages to a specific
app or a specific user via the
Google Cloud Messaging
infrastructure.
Anything from breaking news,
updated sports scores, and
your email messages, or an
updated list of news articles.
This is enough to eliminate
the need for polling and
ensures you never turn on the
radio to communicate with the
server that has nothing
new to download.
So your information architecture
now needs to
determine the urgency of
reflecting each server change
in your app.
You can set up your server using
either HTTP or CCS using
XMPP, and it captures payloads
as JSON or plaintext.
Here we're using JSON to create
a message starting with
the registration IDs
to which we want to
transmit our message.
By default, your app will
receive GCM messages, even if
it's not running and the
phone is on standby.
You can help minimize battery
drain by setting
delay_while_idle to true,
indicating that your message
doesn't need to be sent
immediately, if the device is
on standby.
Instead, these messages will
be queued until the device
becomes active.
In fact, if you also set a
collapse key, only one message
will be sent when the device
does become active.
The collapse key is any
arbitrary string that the GCM
service can use to collapse a
queue of messages addressed to
the same device.
So when the device comes online
or becomes active, it
receives only one message.
There's no guarantee that the
message the queue collapses to
will be the most recent one you
sent, so these messages
are known as send-to-sync and
are best suited to update
tickles that tell your app
simply that there is new data
ready to download.
You can go a step further and
set a time loop before queued
messages expire using the
time-to-live parameter.
This determines how many seconds
the GCM service should
keep your message before
canceling it.
By default, this is set to
four weeks, but you can
dramatically reduce this for
messages you know will be out
of date or replaced over a
shorter time period, which is
a particularly useful feature
for messages with payload
data, included in the form of an
optional JSON object, whose
fields represent key value
pairs of data.
Each message can store up to
4K of data, which will be
delivered as strings within the
intent bundle of received
GCM messages as you
can see here.
These non-collapsible or
message-with-payload messages
are more than a synced tickle.
They're used when you need to
deliver every message, because
every message has different
content.
Notifications are a great
example of how you may use
these payload messages.
By including the current weather
details, commentary
and score after a touchdown
pass, or breaking news
headlines and summaries within
the payload of the GCM message
itself, you're able to update
your users immediately with
nominal incremental
battery impact.
It is possible to use these
collapsed keys with payload
messages, but because the
delivery of order isn't
guaranteed and the collapsed
message isn't guaranteed to be
the last one received, you
need to be careful not to
display outdated information.
If non-collapsible messages with
payloads aren't going to
provide a specific improvement
to the user experience,
send-to-sync messages are a
better option, as they put
less of a burden on the
device battery.
For example, if your server
notifies your app every time
there is a new article or
message, it only needs to
receive one message telling it
that it's time to sync up,
which you can do using a sync
adaptor to initiate the sync,
preferably bundling a number of
batch transfers together,
as described in my Dev.Byte on
batching, bundling, and using
the sync adaptor.
Using Google Cloud Messaging
allows you to totally
eliminate client-side polling
from your applications.
Implemented correctly, you can
configure the messages
transmitted to have as little
impact on the battery as
possible, using techniques
like short-time-to-live
parameters, collapse keys, and
the delay-while-idle parameter
to limit the number of messages
which are actually
transmitted to your app.
By keeping your apps constantly
up to date, you can
minimize latency and help
eliminate the Refresh button.
Used with sync adaptors and
pre-fetching, you can
dramatically improve
the battery
efficiency of your apps.